I hate when Republicans put me in these
kind of positions of like I'm going to
have to defend Hunter Biden I'm not
defending him but here he wanted it to
be a public hearing from the way I hear
it you know what if Congress ever hauled
my butt in for anything like I want this
public like I just really like the
idea that for whatever reason they
didn't want to have I understand he's
going to grandstand he's going to try to
make his point his views Etc but I think
it's fair to say yeah if I'm going to be
haul in front ofong Congress I want it
to be public I think that's a fair
statement I think that's a fair St so
why can't the Republicans say hey you
know what we can handle our own PR for
this we'll let him come in and say what
he wants to say and we'll refute it live
in front of the I'll be open to that but
so he refused to do it unless it's
public and they're okay that violates
the rules you have to do it's not a
violation rules violation what they
wanted it was this on top of Joe Biden
answering reporters questions or like
hey what's up with these business
dealings and he's like you're lying
you're all lying and I'm like oh this is
coming man I just saw this this feels
like it's been coming they don't I don't
think anybody wants him to run as
president and he won't let go I do I
want him to run yeah I'm all for Biden